86 countries co-sponsored ukraine's
resolution in the general assembly
demanding humanitarian access to
civilians and an end to russia's
aggression
it will send a powerful message aimed at
contributing to a breakthrough in
humanitarian action on the ground and
making the aggressor stop its unprovoked
war
france one of the resolutions authors
described the war as a threat to
international peace and
security the project resolution the
draft resolution introduced this morning
by ukraine is the fruit of an inclusive
process and it reflects a balanced
taking account of the proposals made by
countries from all regions there's an
urgent need to act and to reach an
immediate cessation of hostilities
but russia's ambassador called the text
political and disingenuous and as the
speeches continued brought his own
version of a humanitarian resolution to
the more powerful security council
we're submitting for a vote a resolution
which is non-politicized and is in this
way similar to other draft humanitarian
resolutions of the security council this
is something which u.n humanitarian
representatives on the ground would be
very interested in more so than any
humanitarian resolution from the general
assembly
russia's resolution was soundly defeated
with its only support coming from china
the resolution that we saw today was a
cynical effort by russia
to exploit the crisis which they have
caused
their resolution called for respect for
international humanitarian law
but overlooked the fact that they are
committing war crimes
south africa sought a compromise
submitting a humanitarian resolution to
the general assembly which didn't call
out russia it was among 35 countries
that abstained on a vote three weeks ago
condemning russia's aggression
so many countries signed up to speak in
the general assembly hall about the
humanitarian situation the speeches went
on all day and are expected to continue
into thursday the ukrainian draft is
expected to pass given it has nearly 90
co-sponsors the question is by how much
ukraine and its backers are hoping to
show russia's increasing isolation on
the international stage kristen salumi
al-jazeera the united nations